while people were voting in Georgia the
president traveled to Wisconsin a state
that was hugely important for him back
in November he visited a tool
manufacturer to sign an executive order
that he calls by American hire American
it carried a message aimed at his
blue-collar supporters but that message
also contradicts decisions the president
made when he was CEO of the Trump
Organization major Garrett is at the
White House with the difference between
president Trump and businessman Trump
major good morning good morning
president Trump does have a problem when
it comes to preaching by American higher
American it's the same problem he had as
a candidate which of course means it can
be overcome and the problem is this when
it comes to this issue mr. Trump's
history can best be described as do as I
say not as I do by American and higher
American president Trump traveled to
Wisconsin to draw attention to an
executive order that reinforces existing
law to make certain federal dollars give
priority to american-made goods we're
going to do everything in our power to
make sure that more products are stamped
with those wonderful words made in the
USA the president's America first
rhetoric does not match the reality of
business practices that made him
millions many Trump branded products are
manufactured overseas Trump eyeglasses
made in China items from the Trump home
collection made in China now where were
these made and Trump ties well David
Letterman asked about those in 2012 as
highs are made in where China ties are
made in China
many outfits sold under the name of
daughter and now White House aide Ivanka
are also manufactured abroad mainly in
China Ivanka Trump no longer runs the
company we believe jobs must be offered
to American workers first the executive
order also targets the h-1b visa program
which allows companies to hire skilled
foreign labor the White House argues
that program undercuts American workers
mr. Trump has used the visa program to
hire foreign workers at his properties
for many years just two months ago he
applied for an h-2b visa for foreign
nationals services at his golf club
outside New York City in 2015 we asked
about then candidate Trump's routine
hiring of seasonal foreign workers at
mar-a-lago impossible to hire American
workers very hard either they're not
qualified and one of the big thing it's
a seasonal job in that interview mr.
Trump told me he had done everything he
could to hire American workers but they
simply did not want seasonal job that
only lasted a few months now critics
argue if mr. Trump raised his wages at
mar-a-lago those jobs would be more
attractive to workers instead of the
ones from Romania and Haiti he tends to
hire charlie thanks major